is it really smart to produce fuel from
food crops while the global population
is increasing drastically after years of
tough negotiations Parliament and the
council have finally agreed on reducing
the use of first-generation biofuels MEP
is wanted to limited use of these fuels
to no more than six percent in a
transport sector by 2021 fight was about
to cap for first generation biofuel the
seven percent cap we would like to we
would had like to have it slightly lower
the second question we would like to
have a binding target for
second-generation biofuels we didn't get
that second generation biofuels made
from sources such as seaweed or waste
are more environmentally friendly than
first generation biofuels large surfaces
of agricultural land are needed for the
production of first-generation biofuels
which can lead to deforestation and an
increase in greenhouse gas emissions
until now the agriculture Lobby was
quite successful they are of course
seeing a new market arising and that's
why that's why they are promoting their
food crops we use as biofuels after the
proposed directive goes to vote in
plenary member states will have to
comply with the target for
first-generation biofuels within the
next two years